now I hear you know the Arts are overrun
with like leftists and liberals y'all
didn't vote for Biden did you we did not
you know and and at the end of the day
um
I feel like I I knew what was going to
happen that's happening right now I felt
like that came with with that vote in
you know I feel like when when yeah I
feel like when if we were to vote for
Biden it would be to
vote for what we're talking about like
almost a recession you know an increase
in energy we knew when he came in the
gas was going to go to six dollars a
gallon we knew hotels were going to
double we knew so so for us you know
we're seeing our whole lives change and
then not not to to Discount the fact
that in 2020 we were the industry that
they pretty much told your shutdown
you're not playing any concerts you know
the the only article we ever got written
in Rolling Stone about us was that you
know we had number one hits we sold
hundreds of thousands of Records Rolling
Stone ignored us our entire career we
played one outdoor Festival in late 2020
and they called us murders they were